hi wir sind wieder ZDF heute live ganz
herzlich willkommen bei uns im Stream
ihr habt das ja sicher in den
vergangenen Tagen und auch Wochen
mitbekommen immer wieder erobert die
ukrainische Armee Teile des eigenen
Landes von der russischen Armee zurück
und es wird davon gesprochen einige
Expertinnen und Experten sagen das das
ist womöglich an dem Wendepunkt stehen
könnte der Krieg zugunsten der Ukraine
und auch dass die russische Armee gar
nicht diese große Übermacht sei wie es
Putin propagiert hat und wie lange auch
die Annahme schien jetzt hat aber der
bundeswehrinspektor der deutsche
Eberhard Zorn in einem Fokus Interview
gesagt wartet mal Leute ich sehe da
jetzt irgendwie wirklich noch nicht so
wirklich eine Gegenoffensive der Ukraine
und auch die russische Armee die sehe
ich schon noch stärker sogar so stark
eine zweite Front aufmachen zu können
es gibt also unterschiedliche Deutungen
Aussagen und deswegen wollen wir da
heute noch mal detailliert mit euch
gemeinsam reingehen die Frage wie stark
ist Russlands Armee noch und einer der
da tiefe Einblicke und auch Antworten
auf diese Fragen geben kann der ist
heute bei uns zu Gast das ist Ben hodgas
er ist ehemaliger Generalleutnant der US
Army und war davon 2014 bis 2017
Oberkommandeur der US-Streitkräfte für
das Gebiet von Europa und auch der
Nachfolge Länder der Sowjetunion unter
anderem auch Russland heute ist er auch
nato-berater für Logistik so was
beschäftigt euch zu dem Thema was geht
euch durch den Kopf was wollt ihr wissen
schickt uns gerne eure Fragen entweder
direkt in die Chats oder auch per
Mailadresse kommt ZDF
heute-live@zdf.de nimmt euch da jetzt
noch ein bisschen Zeit überlegt
vielleicht kurz denn jetzt bringt uns
Wieders erstmal auf den aktuellen Stand
der Debatte
die ukrainische Armee ist im Osten des
Landes auf dem Vormarsch sie hat
strategisch wichtige Städte
zurückerobert die russischen Truppen
ziehen sich zurück sie hinterlassen
immense Zerstörungen aber auch viel
militärisches Gerät manche Panzer werden
unversehrt von der ukrainischen Armee
erbeutet wie geschwächt ist die
russische Armee nach Einschätzung der
USA braucht Russland dringend neue
Soldaten für den Krieg das
militärversuche immer verzweifelter
Männer für die Front zu finden Einweg um
die Truppenzahlen zu verbessern scheint
Männer im Gefängnissen zu rekrutieren
zum Beispiel für die private
Söldnerfirma Gruppe Wagner seit Mittwoch
kursiert im Netz ein Video es soll den
kremmenderen Geschäftsmann der Goschin
oft auch Koch des Kreml genannt zeigen
wie er für eine Teilnahme am
ukrainekrieg wirbt
der Krieg ist hart er ist nicht wie die
Kriege in Afghanistan oder
Tschetschenien wir gucken wie stark ihr
seid und dann entscheiden wir ob wir
euch nehmen
Deutschlands Rang höchster Soldat der
Generalinspektor der Bundeswehr Eberhard
Zorn warnt jedoch davor Russlands
militärische Stärke zu unterschätzen
auch wenn etwa 60% der Landstreitkräfte
der russischen Streitkräfte im Ukraine
gebunden sind verfügen die restlichen
Landstreitkräfte sowie die russische
Marine und luftschreibkräfte noch über
ungebundene Kapazitäten er könne bislang
auch keine echte gegen Offensive der
Ukraine erkennen so Zorn im
Nachrichtenmagazin Focus er sehe
allenfalls Gegenstöße mit denen man Orte
oder einzelne Frontabschnitte
zurückgewinnen aber nicht Russland auf
breiter Front zurückdrängen kann das
sehen aber viele Militärexperten anders
unter anderem auch unser heutiger Gast
heute Abend bei uns im Stream da haben
wir ihn Ben Hodges Generalleutnant ad
der US Army heute berät er die NATO in
Logistikfragen erst einmal herzlich
willkommen bei uns im Stream schön dass
Sie bei uns sind
vielen Dank dass ich bei Ihnen sein darf
Herr heute ist lassen Sie uns gemeinsam
drauf schauen denn sie haben auch die
Aussagen von Herrn Zorn die wir gerade
gesehen haben bei Twitter schon einmal
analysiert und sie sprechen da von einer
atemberaubend dürftigen Analyse das
sehen wir hier gerade in ihrem Tweet da
wäre die erste Frage an Sie warum liegt
ihrer Meinung nach Herr Zorn da so
daneben
natürlich noch zu früh dran zu denken
dass der Signal ist aber es ganz klar
dass die ukrainische gegen Offensive die
Russen überrascht hat das ist ganz klar
dass die Russen nicht den Kampf Willen
haben
sehr Probleme mit der Anzahl der Truppen
die Logistik ist in einer schwachen
Position
85% der russischen Militärs sind ja der
Ukraine und die verlieren und als ich
dann
Generalinspektor Zorn hörte dass er
sagte die Russen könnten jetzt weiter
Front eröffnen und das sei kein
für
Generalinspektor Zorn er ist ein Freund
von mir aber ich dachte es wäre einfach
wichtig mal etwas gegen diese
Einschätzung zu sagen denn
wir denken dass die Russen wann auch
immer irgendwo angreifen können dann
hält uns das Zeug davon ab die Ukraine
entsprechend zu unterstützen
dann gehen wir vielleicht auf die also
sie haben die Analyse ja beschrieben als
als
atemberaubendürftig was sind denn
konkret ihre Gegenargumente ihre
Position zu der aktuellen Situation als
Einordnung
anschaue was die Russen im Moment machen
was Sie erreichen können nach sechs
Monaten mit allen Vorteilen die sie
hatten
sie haben über 50.000 Soldaten verloren
getötet mehr als 2000 Panzer zerstört
das Logistiksystem hält nicht stand
gegenüber dem was die brauchen also der
Gedanke dass sie irgendwie eine zweite
Front aufmachen könnten Leningrad oder
an der Grenze mit Finnland oder in
Moldawien oder in der Ostsee also das
glaube ich nicht die russische Marine
ist im Schwarzen Meer die verstecken
sich hinter der Krim
und die kommen nicht nah an die
ukrainische Küste ran obwohl die Ukraine
keine Marine hat die russische Luftwaffe
die pflegt dich zu gerne über Ukraine
die bleiben über Belarus oder Russland
denn die haben Angst vor der
ukrainischen duftverteidigung die
ukrainische Armee wird jeden Tag größer
die russische
Armee rekrutiert jetzt schon
Gefängnisinsassen ich sehe da keinen
Hinweis darauf dass der Kreml Grund zur
Hoffnung hat irgendwo eine neue Front zu
eröffnen
und deswegen
müssen wir den Ukrain ergeben was Sie
brauchen damit die auch erfolgreich sein
können und diese Operation gegen
Russland beenden können mit einem Sieg
und ihr ganzes Territorium
zurückgewinnen können einschließlich der
Krim
ja auf die konkreten Forderungen und was
ist da vielleicht noch braucht da gehen
wir im späteren Verlauf unseres
Gesprächs natürlich noch mal darauf ein
sie haben gerade auch schon beschrieben
und beziehen sich dann natürlich auch
noch mal auf die Aussagen von Herrn Zorn
der eben auch in dem Fokus Interview
gesagt hat dass er schon das Potenzial
sehen würde eine zweite Front von
russischer Seite dass die aufgebaut
werden könnte
sie haben auch geschrieben auf Twitter
dass solche Aussagen auch so ein
bisschen sinnbildlich dafür sind für das
Denken der deutschen Elite da zitiere
ich sie jetzt mal was meinen Sie genau
damit und was würden Sie sagen müsste
sich da in den Köpfen vielleicht auch
ändern
immer wieder höre von entweder früheren
liters oder jetzigen Militärs aus der
deutschen Bundeswehr oder Leuten im
Ministerium
und das hört man auch an anderen Stellen
in der Regierung
die sprechen so als ob der Sieg
Russlands unvermeidbar sei als das die
Ukraine niemals die Krim zurückerobern
könnte
und die ermutigen die Ukraine zu
verhandeln und oft zu kämpfen weil sie
nicht glauben dass man die Russen
besiegen könnte
Generation hat selber vor ein paar
gesagt dass er vor ein paar Wochen
nicht geglaubt hätte dass die Ukraine
etwas schaffen was sie jetzt geschafft
haben meine Kritik ist nicht
gegen general Zorn ich respektiere ihn
und er hat Zugang zu Informationen die
ich nicht kenne aber was ich sehe ist
eine russische Armee die erschöpft ist
die haben nicht genügend Soldaten und
das zu tun was sie wollen sie können
keine general mobil machen durchführen
fast 80 50 Prozent der russischen
Soldaten sind in der Ukraine involviert
und sie können die Ukraine nicht
niederringen und deswegen glaube ich
also das Denken was ich so mitbekomme
von der sogenannten deutschen Elite ist
dass sie einfach nicht glauben
oder also die glauben dass die Russen
sehr stark sind
sie sind aber nicht so stark ich habe
aber auch schon Fehler gemacht vor
Februar dachte ich die russische Armee
wäre viel besser als wir das jetzt
gesehen habe ich habe mich geehrt
es wundert mich also nicht dass man da
Fehler hatschätzung macht was mich
wundert ist das nach sechs Monaten was
die Russen gemacht haben was die
Ukrainer gemacht haben und der wundert
mich dass irgendeiner noch glauben
könnte dass die Ukraine die Russen
niederringen könnten mit unserer helfen
natürlich
im Juni haben sie auch getwittert und
gesagt das passt jetzt ganz gut zu den
Entwicklungen die so in diesen ganzen
Verlauf zu sehen gewesen sind da haben
sie getwittert dass man Ende August
Mitte September womöglich sehen können
dass Russland nicht mehr über die
angriffsinitiative verfügen würde Frage
also an sie hat sich das aus ihren
Informationen und dem was sie sehen und
beschreiben bewahrheitet und an welchem
Punkt des Krieges stehen wir dann
womöglich
von klausewitz hat in seinem Buch über
den Krieg den
kombinationspunkt beschrieben das ist
der Punkt in einem Angriff einer
Offensive wo die angreifenden Kräfte die
Dynamik verlieren keine Ressourcen mehr
haben zu viele verletzten Todes sie
können nicht mehr weiter angreifen das
heißt das ist der kombinationspunkt und
als Verteidiger will man den Punkt
antizipieren dann kann man nämlich
heraus planen im Sinne einer
Gegenoffensive und da kann man also
sehen dann wo der schwächste Punkten
davon ist und das passiert jetzt die
russische Logistik hat versagt
die haben so viele Verluste
und die Russen waren deutlich in der
Lage Land Streitkräfte Luftstreitkräfte
und Seestreitkräfte die sind nicht
integriert
und ich hatte damals gesagt im August
würden sie an Stärke verlieren und
könnten dann nicht mehr den Angriff
vortragen und hält den kombinationspunkt
erreicht die Ukraine haben auch im
Generalstab klausewitz studiert und die
wussten dass der Punkt kommt und die
haben ihre eigene gegen Offensive
wahrscheinlich mindestens vor zwei
Monaten schon geplant und haben einfach
auf die richtige Zeit zum Gegenschlag
gewartet und
das ist jetzt dann Kombination von guter
Planung und Vorbereitung und exzellenten
verschleierungsplänen die russischen
Truppen wurden nach kerstone gezogen
statt das in Kaki bleiben in bleiben
wurde echte Angriffspunkt war
und dann die neuen Wappen aus
Deutschland die Haubitzen mit langer
Reichweite und die dadurch wurde die
heimatwaffen dass ich für die russische
Logistik zerstört die russische Logistik
wurde verdichtet das war Teil der
Vorbereitung und ich denke man muss die
Ukraine loben wegen ihrer Disziplin die
Russen wussten nicht dass die Ukrainer
tatsächlich tausende von Truppen
sammeln würden für diese Chance in der
Nähe von
Kerkhoff und als sie vor ein paar Tagen
dann 14 Tagen Angriffen waren die Russen
schon abgezogen nach Carson und die sind
wirklich reingefallen auf die
versteigerungstaktik und die Ukraine
waren dann in der Lage anzugreifen
deswegen haben sie bis jetzt tausende
von Quadratkilometern ihres Territoriums
wieder zurückgewonnen und tausende von
russischen Gefangenen gemacht und die
haben das Bild dieses Krieges und die
Dynamik verändert ich denke diese
Dynamik kann ich mir umgekehrt werden
die Russen können das nicht mehr
aufheben und umdrehen
scheint wirklich nicht in der Lage zu
sein irgendwo noch mal diese Dynamik
umzukehren
passend dazu habe ich auch immer
natürlich unseren Chat und die Fragen
aus der Community im Blicke hat es ich
leite Ihnen vielleicht eine mal weiter
ganz kurz Markus W auf youtube hat
erstmal gefragt das haben sie gerade
schon eingeschätzte Hottes
würde nämlich interessieren ob eine
generalmobilisierung in Russland
definitiv ausgeschlossen ist wenn ich
Sie richtig verstanden habe haben sie
gesagt dass das nicht möglich ist und
die zweite Frage von Mario auf Youtube
die geht so ein bisschen in das was sie
gerade gesagt haben sie sehen nicht mehr
die Kraft Russlands da wieder in eine
angriffsspirale zu kommen welche das ist
nämlich die Frage von Mario welche
realistischen Möglichkeiten hat den
Putin überhaupt gerade noch
das sind zwei sehr gute Fragen
und natürlich wir alle versuchen zu
verstehen was im Kopf von Präsident
Putin vorgeht und dem Kremlin im Kreml
wir hören da die Argumente die gehen hin
und her selbst in der Öffentlichkeit in
den russischen Medien einige
beschuldigen den Kreml andere den
russischen Generalstab einige denken
dass die Russen mehr tun sollten manche
denken die Russen sollten den Krieg
aufhören
ich denke der Grund warum der krempelt
keine general Mobilmachung verkündet ist
das dann Präsident Putin erklären müsste
was da eigentlich passiert und so weit
habt ihr versucht die russische
Bevölkerung zu schützen und zu verändern
dass die Russen verstehen was eigentlich
passiert und das wird ja dieses ganze
Bärchen Russlands unterminieren warum
man da überhaupt eine Ukraine kämpft
denke ich wenn jetzt keine general mobil
machen ein weiterer Grund ist es wäre
einfach die wird sich einfach schämen
denn keiner würde kommen keiner will in
der russischen Armee dienen die wissen
wir was passiert wenn sie in die Ukraine
geschickt werden das ist ja auch schon
so bei der wagnergruppe die gehen jetzt
in die Gefängnisse um Rekruten zu finden
und selbst da will keiner in die Ukraine
selbst wenn ich falsch liege
selbst wenn die eine Mobilisierung
machen und hunderttausend Leute würden
dann gemustert dann haben die ja immer
noch nicht die Ausrichtung oder die Zeit
um trainiert zu werden um wirklich etwas
auszurichten
die Schritte die erforderlich sind für
alle Mobilisierung die Schritte sind
noch gar nicht ergriffen worden die
behördlichen Maßnahmen sind nicht
ergriffen worden und es gibt auch keine
Orte für die Grundausbildung selbst wenn
man das morgen ankündigen würde wird das
Monate dauernd bevor irgendjemand mit
Ausrüstung und Grundausbildung in einer
Einheit geschickt würde um dann in der
Ukraine zu kämpfen
die Ukraine wird während des Winters
weiterkämpfen die Welt der nicht
aufhören die geben den Russen keine
Chance sich wieder zu Umzug gruppieren
und das denke ich wird da passieren ja
welche Optionen hätte der Kreml noch
natürlich gibt es immer die Option über
die wir sprechen das ist die Möglichkeit
das Einsatzes einer Nuklearwaffe oder
chemiewaffe aber ich denke auch das ist
unwahrscheinlich
zunächst mal wenn die Russen eine
Nuklearwaffe nutzten innerhalb der
Ukraine da würde das die Situation auf
dem Gefechtsfeld nicht verändert selbst
wenn die größeren Städte zerstört würden
die haben ja keine Truppen die dann
durch die Lücke durchgeschickt werden
könnten also sie hätten keinen
wirklichen militärischen Vorteil und
zweitens
und das ist der wichtigere Grund wenn
Russland an der taktische Nuklearwaffe
in der Ukraine benutzt
dann wäre das für die USA und
Großbritannien nicht wirklich nicht zu
reagieren dann würden die USA direkt
involviert wurden in dem Konflikt das
wollen will der Krümel nicht wenn die
USA direkt involviert werden dann hätte
das ganz schlimme Wirkungen für die
russischen Kräfte die russische Antwort
war nicht notwendigerweise oder
amerikanische Reaktion wenn ich so
stückchenweise eine nukleare Reaktions
wenn vielleicht Luftschläge machen also
etwas sie würden größten Teil der
russischen Basen in auf der Krim und im
Topas zerstören und der Kreml weiß dass
und aus diesen Gründen
weil ich auch glaube dass
Putin nicht verrückt ist
illegal oder kriminell aber nicht
verrückt und körperlich dass die Leute
um ihn herum verrückt sind und deswegen
glaube ich nicht dass sie eine Atomwaffe
einsetzen würden
ja das beantwortet auch viele Fragen
hier bei uns aus dem Chat zum Beispiel
Holger Bastard eben das auch gefragt die
wahrscheinlich der Einsatz von nuklearen
Waffen durch Russland ist das haben sie
gerade schon eingeschätzt vielleicht
schauen wir dann auf der anderen Seite
auch noch mal auf den Aspekt den Sie
angesprochen haben und zwar den Punkt im
Verlauf dieses russischen angriffskriegs
gegen die Ukraine wir sind
Geländegewinne der ukrainischen Armee
oder Rückeroberungen des eigenen des
eigenen Landes und sie und auch einige
weitere Experten sprechen gerade von dem
kombinationspunkt von einem möglichen
Wendepunkt wie könnte denn dann der
zeitliche Verlauf weitergehen also wird
es noch größere Schritte in diesem Jahr
geben oder auch erst im nächsten Jahr
ich wünschte ich
wüsste mit Sicherheit wieder zeitliche
Ablauf ist ich denke die ukrainischen
Truppen werden weiterhin Druck ausüben
auf Russland sodass die russischen
Kräfte sich der nicht wieder
umgruppieren können und es gibt da eine
psychologischen Aspekt im Krieg wenn
andere Seite wirklich die Dynamik hat
und die andere Seite ist müde geschlagen
die generelle Tod oder Lichtwirkung
nicht wirksam dann kollabiert alles
ich weiß nicht ob alles kollabieren wird
oder etwas sofort aber was wir sehen ist
das viele russische Soldaten weglaufen
und die lassen ihre Geräte zurück
perfekte
artilleriestücke oder Panzer und
ähnliches
und die ukrainische Region wird
weiterhin die russischen Soldaten
ermutigen aufzugeben sollen Ihnen sagen
sie werden dann ihr werdet überleben ihr
werdet versorgt und ihr kommt dann
zurück nach Russland denn ihr wollt ja
nicht hier leben und das wird auch seine
Wirkung tragen also Wirkung haben und
die ukrainischen Truppen die bewegen
sich langsam immer mehr Richtung Grimm
das ist ja der Schlüssel die Krim ist
der Schlüssel
wenn die
Ukraine nagellos sind dass sie heimas
einsetzen können oder andere
Raketenwerfer das was Deutschland zum
Beispiel an die Ukraine liefert und wenn
die dann russische Ziele innerhalb der
Kim erreichen können
dann wird die Krim für die Russen
nutzlos die
Schwarzmeerflotte wird dann ähnlich bei
ins Wasser obwohl bleiben können und die
Truppen können da nicht mehr von den
Militärbasen dort operieren und da wird
es einen großen Verkehrsstau geben auf
dieser großen Brücke die die Krim mit
dem Festland in Russland verbindet
ich denke dass die Ukraine die Brücke
stehen lassen werden als offene Tür
damit die Russen wissen ihr könnt gehen
wir lassen euch gehen
gewissen Zeit tja wann wird das
passieren könnte das könnte Anfang
nächsten Jahres beginnen
das kommt drauf an ob die Ukraine
ihre
Positionen der langstrickwaffen lag noch
an die Krim ranbringen können das ist
wichtig für Deutschland die USA
Großbritannien für uns alle die wir die
Ukraine unterstützen dass wir
zusammenstehen
in unserer Unterstützung und wir müssen
alles liefern was wir versprochen haben
zu liefern und so wird die Ukraine auch
gewinnen
ja das reiht sich nahtlos auch in die
Stimmung im Chat ein es gibt viele viele
Kommentare auch pro weitere
Waffenlieferungen vor allen Dingen was
da gefordert wird schwere Panzer und
Kampf Flugzeuge Herr hat es dann sind
wir doch auch bei dem Thema was
natürlich seit der russischen Invasion
immer wieder auch ein zentrales Anliegen
der ukrainischen Regierung der
ukrainischen Seite ist die Lieferung
schwerer Waffen und vor allen Dingen
auch die Forderung nach Kampfpanzern die
deutsche Rolle die war da lang am Anfang
sehr zurückhaltend mittlerweile gibt es
mehr Unterstützung nur trotzdem noch
nicht die geforderten Kampfpanzer dazu
gibt es heute ein Zitat von
eu-kommissionspräsidentin Ursula von der
Leyen die hat bei ihrem Besuch in Kiew
jetzt tatsächlich auch noch mal der
Bild-Zeitung gesagt wenn die Ukraine das
von uns fordert dann sollten wir auf sie
hören dann sollten wir das auch liefern
wie sehen Sie das wie sehen sie da die
Rolle Deutschlands sollte das kommen und
auch von anderen weiteren Ländern
natürlich eine komplizierte Frage und
Situation
ich möchte drei Punkte ansprechen
zunächst mal ja auf jeden Fall wir
sollten Panzer liefern
Ministerin Lambrecht hat Recht die
Vereinigten Staaten habe ich auch keiner
Abrams Panzer geliefert und die Briten
auch keine Challenger geliefert
und alle sprechen darüber dass die
Deutschen keine Leopard Panzer liefern
oder Mara Schützenpanzer ich denke wir
sollten
dieser Panzer liefern an die Ukraine
denn diese Fähigkeit zusätzlich zu mehr
Raketenwerfern und zu mehr
raketenverteidigungswaffen würde das
ganze schneller beenden
diese Panzer
sind ja keine Autos
man fährt nicht einfach nur irgendwo hin
die führen zu logistischen
Herausforderungen alle Teile und
Komponenten des Leopards unterscheiden
sich von denen das Abrams Panzers und
von denen der anderen Panzer die die
Ukraine jetzt benutzen die Ukraine
Arbeiten keine Schwierigkeiten haben
zu lernen wie sie die Geräte bedienen
die lernen sehr schnell
aber wir müssen ehrlich sein über die
logistische Herausforderung wenn Sie ein
Leo haben oder ein Abrams dann brauchen
sie auch
Wartungsteile und Personal es ist nicht
nur mit der Lieferung getan ich bin mir
nicht sicher ob die ukrainische Logistik
dafür bereit ist aber wir sollten auf
jeden Fall liefern
Deutschland liefert ja sehr viele Waffen
und Fähigkeiten damit
die Leute wissen das oft nicht denn die
Botschaft die aus Berlin kommt ist sehr
gemischt man hört fast jede Woche einen
neuen Grund warum irgendetwas nicht
geliefert wird
man könnte also denken Deutschland täte
nicht genug
aber es wird schon sehr viel getan von
Seiten Deutschlands was helfen würde
wäre
wenn Kanzler Schulz Präsident beiden und
andere Führer öffentlich sagen würden
wir wollen dass die Ukraine gewinnt ganz
spitze Fisch wir wollen dass die Ukraine
gewinnen und wir werden alles tun was
notwendig ist um das sicherzustellen
dass sie gewinnen
hier geht es sehr um eine Demokratie die
eine Autokratie
besichtige zum europäische Bürger die
gegenüber Russland verteidigt werden
jeder hat heute die Nachricht gesehen
die 500 Leichen von unschuldige Menschen
in der Stadt isyum die exekutiert worden
sind durch die Russen darüber reden wir
hier geht es nicht um eine theoretische
akademische Frage es geht hier darum
Russland zu stoppen dass tausende
unschuldige Menschen
tötet direkt tötet oder dadurch tötet
dass Raketen in Ohnhäuser geschossen
werden ich weiß nicht warum es bei der
Kontroverse gehen soll wir sollten
einfach alles tun was möglich ist dass
die Ukraine so schnell wie möglich
gewinnen
klare eindringliche Worte von Ben Hodges
hier bei ZDF heute live ehemaliger
ja Generalleutnant der US Army für die
europäischen Länder und auch Teile der
ehemaligen Sowjetunion unter anderem
Russland heute nato-berater für Logistik
klare Analysen präzise Analysen und auch
noch die Forderung herzlichen Dank für
das Gespräch und liebe Grüße
ich danke Ihnen dass ich hier sein
durfte
danke auch an euch fürs zuschauen hier
bei ZDF heute live macht euch noch einen
schönen Abend bis zum nächsten Mal
tschüss